Scientists are embarking on a massive effort to CT-scan all vertebrates--
from bats to turtles to squirrels.
Countless animal specimens are preserved and
stored away in museum collections,
making them difficult for scientists, and the public, to access.
But the plan to “scan all vertebrates”
will change that
by creating 3D models of the animals and uploading them to a free online database
Over the next four years, 16 universities and museums across the United States.
will scan more than 20,000 fluid-preserved animals,
covering about 15,000 different species.
Even though that’s only 22% of the 68,000
vertebrate species,
they will be carefully picked to cover over 80% of living vertebrate genera.
To speed things up, researchers have made
“fish burritos,” where multiple specimens,
such as these piranhas, are wrapped, stacked,
and scanned together.
This unique view of vertebrates has already
led to discoveries, including new species,
such as this clingfish, that was hiding in
a museum for several years.
They can also help scientists understand new
quirks about animal diets and lifestyles,
such as this Philippine flat-headed frog that
ate a crab before being preserved,
or this other frog that’s so tiny, the ant inside
its belly is almost as big as its head!
Texas A&M will be in charge of scanning anything large.
In the past they’ve scanned an eel, a bowhead whale fetus, and even a shark.
The project will also pick about 1,000 specimens
to soak in an iodine dye,
which boosts the contrast on soft tissues,
improving the view of the muscles, circulatory system, and brain.
“Scan-all-vertebrates” is a basic science
initiative to inspire new research
and is a huge leap forward in digitally preserving, and sharing, biodiversity on Earth.